I think the biggest thing I want to work
on with my girlfriend's is telling the
difference between empowerment and
entitlement it's a fine line very easy
to confuse those two like I have this
one girlfriend she thinks she's very
empowered but she's actually just
entitled and it comes out in the way
that she complains that no man is good
enough for her
even though all she does is talk about
astrology and go to music festivals she
has no concept of what she deserves like
she will go to a music festival for five
days and do drugs the entire time and
then she'll come back and spike I told
you there's just no good man out there
like no there-there are good men out
there there's at home with they're good
women you're never gonna meet them
because they're not at Burning Man
watching you puke on your Native
American Indian costume
[Applause]